good morning to you it is a wednesday
morning we thank you so much for joining
us on good day and let's talk about
going to space t-minus 12 hours until
history gets made today here on earth
and in space this is so incredibly cool
i love it it is elon musk's spacex will
attempt to launch the inspiration for it
is the world's first all-civilian crude
mission to travel into space the
flight's mission is to raise money and
awareness for saint jude children's
research hospital because one of the
astronauts is actually a cancer survivor
so the five-hour launch window it opens
at 502 this afternoon the capsule will
blast off from nasa's kennedy space
center in florida
here's a look at the crew who'll be on
board it's commanded by shift four
payments ceo jared isaacman pilot and
backup commander is cyan proctor she'll
be the fourth black woman to travel in
space and she's a geoscientist john
that's right there's also a mission
specialist christopher sombroski medical
officer haley arsenault in fact that 29
year old that's the youngest american on
board the first with the prosthesis and
first pediatric cancer survivor to go
into space the flight's mission very
personal to her she spent a year in
treatment at st jude's which is
benefiting from this flight but she was
10 at the time now she's a physician
physician assistant there
surviving cancer made me tough
and i think it taught me a lot about
going out of my comfort zone and the
journey is been so much fun i think
going to space will almost be the cherry
on top of the most incredible year i've
ever had
love that the crew is going to orbit the
earth for three whole days before
touching back down so that's a proper
space flight guys to actually be in
space for three days hold three whole
days to really get the full experience
up there what an incredible venture for
all of them and for us down here on
earth being able to watch you know
somebody that we could look up to and an
average citizen
isn't it unusual that civilians now are
just blasting off in rockets like every
day it
pretty soon won't be that big of a deal
no it just shows that it is a big deal
we all have the right stuff you know all
those astronauts back in the day amazing
uh amazing people but you know we all
have the right stuff
too yeah well maybe down the road if we
have enough money